ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
بعد منافسه محتدمه وجوله ثانيه هي الاولى
في تاريخ تركيا الانتخابي فاز رئيس التركي
رجب طيبه اردوغان برئاسه لولايه ثالثه بعد
خوضه لاكبر تحدي سياسي كما وصف مراقبون
فوز يرسخ فيه اردوغان حكمه لخمس سنوات
جديده مع تبرى ضربه كبرى للمعارضه التي
لطالما اتهمته بتقويض اسس الديمقراطيه فوز
اردوغان بمقعد رئاسه طرح تساؤلات عديده عن
سر قدرته على الحشد والاقناع بعد كل هذه
السنوات وتساؤلات اخرى ايضا متعلقه بمدى
قدرته على مواجهات التحديات القادمه
وابرزها الظروف الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها
تركيا
نتحدث مشاهدينا عن تراجع القدره الشرائيه
وعن ارتفاع مستمر كذلك لمعدل التضخم
بالاضافه الى تراجع قيمه الليرات التركيه
التي انخفضت الى مستوى قياسي جديد هذه
المره بمجرد الاعلان عن فوزه الى جانب ذلك
يبقى تحدي اعاده اعمار المحافظات التي
ضربها زلزال من بين ابرز التحديات
الداخليه وربما اكثرها استعجالا كما يطالب
الاتراك واما عن سياسته الخارجيه فالملفات
عديده وبعضها تضع اردوغان في توتر مع
الغرب فرئيس التركي ماضن في عمليه التنقيب
عن الغاز في البحر الابيض المتوسط متجاوزا
الموقف اليوناني والغضب الاوروبي كذلك
واما عن الحرف اوكرانيا وعن مستقبل حلف
شمال الاطلسي الناتو فيرى تقرير لاسوشي ان
اردوغان سيكثف مشاوراته مع الغرب وقد تطغى
عليها بعض التعقيدات واتفقت صحيفه مع هذه
القراءه حيث شككت في تحسن العلاقه بين
انقره واشنطن تحديدا على خلفيه الغاء
الاتفاق لتوريط مقاتلات اف 35 لانقره
ويبقى السؤال الرئيسي هل سيتخذ اردوغان
نهجا جديدا في سياسته الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
مصطفى غزران المحلل السياسي اهلا بك من
اسطنبول كذلك فائق بولوت المحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
مع الاستاذ فائق استاذ فائق في الواقع
تحديات كبيره يتحدث عنها البعض موجوده على
طويله رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ولكن
قبل الخوض فيها والحديث عنها ومناقشتها
اسمح لي ان افهم منكما لماذا فاز اردوغان
البعض يطرح اسئله عديده اردوغان اضاف خمس
سنوات جديده الى عقدين من حكمه ما الذي
يمتلكه اردوغان استاذ فائق ولم تتمكن
المعارضه من امتلاكه حتى تخسر وتسمح له
باضافه الخمس سنوات الجديده
يعني النقطه الاولى بالنسبه لان هو
استفاده واستخدم موظف كل امكانيه الدوله
اللي اقناع مواطنين والشارع
يعني في كل النواحي يعني ليس في الناحيه
واحده ناحيه ثانيه يعني اكثر من
منافسه يعني في التواصل واتصال مع جماهير
في الشارع وبحيش يخطب خطابا
هذا خطاب طبعا
يهدف الى اثاره مشاعرهم
القوميه والوطنيه والدينيه وما الى ذلك
فالسيد
رضوان فنان في هذه في هذه في هذا المجال
النقطه الثالثه ممكن ان نقول سيد رجب طيب
اردوغان انه ايضا من حيث
يعني نجح في تحويل النظر او لفت النظر
الجماهير عن اقتصاد يعني ازمه الاقتصاديه
غلاء المعيشات تضخم المالي وما الى ذلك
فهي نقطه الضعف ضعف السيد رضا
اولا انه حول هذه النقطه الى النقطه القوه
بحيث
بحيث جماهير غادت نظر عن هذه الازمات
كبيره جدا يعني مباشره
بدات قلت بانه هو حول
مشكله الظروف الاقتصاديه ولكن حولها باي
اتجاه
كمال الجمله
احكام الجمله بحيث هو يعني جعل انه مساله
الامن القومي مساله الارهاب ومساله خلينا
التدخلات الخارجيه قوسين وهذه كل المسائل
على ان هناك اعضاء كبار جدا لتركيا هذه
الدول تتدخل في الشؤون التركيه يوميا وكذا
بكل بالرغم من كل هناك مؤامرات خارجيه
داخليه الى ذلك حاول يعني حاولت نقطه
الضعف من يعني من حيث الاقتصاد الى نقطه
خلينا القوه بحيث جماهير يعني
صادقت صادقت به في
مساله الامن القومي مساله التدخلات
الخارجيه مسيره المؤامرات هي يعني
في موقع صداره في اجنده اجنه الانتخابات
هذه
كان رجب طيبه اردوغان اقرب الى الشعب
وازكى من المعارضه ما خوله الفوز في هذا
الانتخابات
نعم الى حد كبير منذ البدايه اصلا شخصيه
رئيس رجب طيب اردو جذابه بالنسبه للقاعده
او للشعب التركي لذلك يعني ما انفقه عن
طبعا تشبث به او
اتيت به الى حد الان يعني الناس جربوه
وعرفوه منذ عشرين سنه
بالمقابل لم يعرفه لم يجربوا
طبعا وعوده كانت نظريه
وطبعا وعوض رئيس تركيا كان كان يعتمد على
ما بناه منذ عشرين سنه يعني هناك بعض
الاسباب اصلا
لفوزه الرئيس اردوغان اولا مارس سياسه شعب
شعبويه كما قال او اشار اليه فايت
هناك هذه الشعبويه سياسه الشعب ببوريه ادى
الى صعود اليمين
وتحالف مع اليمين
الصاعد وهذا مكنه من الفوز مجددا وايضا
طبعا الناس يخافون عن الارهاب عوده
الارهاب كما حصل الفين 2015 وما الى ذلك
لذلك ربما
تحالف هزو شعب الجمهور بهزب الاخضر او
يسار الاخضر مما ادى الى خوف بعض بعض
الطيارات في تركيا عن
عوده الارهاب او عمليه الارهابيه مما زاد
من اصوات اليمين تركيا او صعود اليمين
في داخل تركيا ولكن حضرتك سيد مصطفى تحدثت
عن استعمال رجب طيب اردوغان للشعبويه
للخطاب الشعبوي كوسيله اعتقد بانه الاستاذ
سائق تحدث عن خطاب شعبي قال بانه هو اقرب
للشعب لا اعلم استاذ سائق هناك طبعا كما
تعلمون حضراتكم فرق بين الخطاب الشعبي او
الموجه او ان يكون اقرب للشعب والخطاب
الشعبوي استاذ فائق هل استخدم رجب طيب
اردوغان الخطاب الشعبوي لبلوغ اهدافه
يعني يعني هو
استخدم يعني
كلا خلينا نقول كل نقطتين او كل موضوعين
يعني لانه هو معروف انه تربى السيد
طبعا خلينا نقول الطريقه الصوفيه جماعه
الصوفيه النقشه بانديه ولنعرف انه هذه
الطرق النقشبنديه او الطرق الصوفيه هي من
يكون ويجد ان يكون هناك يعرف انه خطابه
الناس
جدا يفهموا في يعني في السنتهم ما يدور في
باله وما يطلبون يرغبون في هذه النقطه
يعني هو شعبي ولكن ان واحد اخرى كادام
هناك خدابات الشعبيه يعني حتى قد تكون هذه
الخطوات الرخيصه جدا ولكن هو يعني هو يكتب
بخطاب شعبويه ايضا شعبيه بحيث انه
تتهيج الجماهير
[موسيقى]
وبعدين انه يحبه تحبه
يعني لو قطعتك يعني لا تغضب لانه نحن
نتفاعل مع بعض في الحقيقه فاتمنى اختصار
فقط التفسير حتى نطرح المزيد من النقاط لو
سمحت استاذ ثائر سؤال حضرتك استاذ مصطفى
شكرا على التفهم استاذ مصطفى تحدث حضرتك
على اليمين في داخل التركي وكانك المحت
الى ان اردوغان يتحمل المسؤوليه في
اعاده او طرح يمين قوي في داخل تركيا هل
توافق هذا الطرح اولا هل اشرت الى ذلك منذ
قليل
نعم خطابات والعمه ربما ادت الى هذه
النقطه او تعزيز اليمين او صعود اليمين
التركي مجددا على اساس هو يعني
او استعمل الوتر
يعني
يمينه وختابات اليمينيه ماثره على قاعده
اليمين يمين تركي قبل الانتخابات لم يكن
هناك صوت لليمين لم يتوقع اصلا اي استطلاع
طري ان اليمين يلعب دورا كبيرا في
الانتخابات التي جرت امس اذا كانت هناك
مفاجاه جدا اين اتت هذه المفاجاه على اساس
من خوف الناس من تجدد الارهاب او انبعاث
عمليه لارهابيه جديده في جنوب شرق تركيا
وما الى ذلك اذا ربما
هو دفع بعض الناس ان يعتقدوا ان هناك
احتمال نشوب عمليه ارهابيه مجددا سنوات
القادمه خوفا من ذلك يعني كما يقال ان
الانسان عضو ما جهل وقاعده المؤيده
والتنميه لا يعرفون طبعا
يصنف على انه
رجل من جانب الاخر ليس من جانب المحافظين
لان كتله محافظه في تركيا يصل
65% وعاده هم يؤيدون احزاب اليمينيه او
احزاب المحافظه هذا ما حصل اولا الشيء
ثانيا له خطابات رنان او خطابات مؤثره جدا
لانه هو درس في ائمه مدرسه الائمه
والخطباء عندما كان يدرس كان يخطب دائما
ليل نهار
ويزاول مسامرات الليليه
مكنه من الخطاب هذا الخلاب او خطابه اثر
في الشعب
في خطاباته وفي كلمته ولكن سابقى معك
تحدثت عن الحضور حضور القوميين وقلت بانه
حضورهم كان ملفت في هذه الانتخابات استاذ
فائق هل تتفق مع الاستاذ مصطفى بانه هذا
الظهور من جديد متعلق بملف الارهاب ومخاوف
الاتراك من الارهاب ام ان رياح القوميه
تهب بين الفينه والاخرى على تركيا لان
القوميه عقيده كما يقول البعض اسس لها او
اسست منذ
مصطفى كمال اتاتورك
يعني طبعا ما اسسه
مصطفى كما لا تترك هو ممكن ان نقول نسميه
وطنيه ولكن قوميه شيء اخر قوميه في تركيا
تعني انه التورانيه يعني ترانيا بحيث يعني
تدعو يعني جمال كل الاتراك الموجودين في
انحاء العالم مختلفه
من من سيد بن ويجور حتى خلينا ناخذ بالقان
وما الى ذلك هذه هلا فرق في في عفوا حركه
يعني
حتى ممكن ان نقول حركه القوميه لها يعني
يعني ماضي عريق جدا بحيث قط ظهرت هذه
الحركه منذ اربعينات في خمسينات والستينات
ايضا حتى هذه الحركه القوميه يعني اختلف
تتشكلت الى الحكومه ايطاليه مع حساب
محافظه وما الى ذلك مثلا يعني في احدث
سليمان دمران كان حركه القوميه موجوده في
طبق موجوده فكان قدر حزب الحركه الاسلاميه
يعني متمثله بالسيد فهو كان يعني
متحالف مع رجب طيبه
فيما بعد يعني بعض الثمانين حتى في نهايه
الثمانين ايضا عندما يعني قويين
الجبهه الاسلاميه ممكن ان نقول لا لا
يتجاوز
عتبه
عشره فهذا اتفقوا مثلا في السيد نجمتين
اتفقوا بحيث بصوره مشتركه شاركوا في
انتخابات وطبعا فازوا على نواب يمكنهم ان
يمثلوا في برلمان التركي هذا يعني تقليديا
هناك التدخلات بين قوميه وبين يعني ممكن
نقول معقول اسلاميه
ان اثرنا الموضوع وضعناه كذلك في اطاره
لنفهم لان هناك تساؤلات عديده تخص
المعارضه حضور القوميين الى هذه
الانتخابات والذي اعتبرتها ملفت سعيد
مصطفى ولكن
التحديات كيف ستكون سيد مصطفى بمعنى هل
التحديات ستخص الداخل اكثر ام السياسه
الخارجيه لاردوغان والتي نعلم بان هناك
ملفات شائكه معقده وجدت حساسه في هذه
الاثناء
ابدا اريد ان اشير الى نقطه ان الرئيس
التركي
كان كان هو يعارض اصلا القوميه او القومي
القوميجيين او قوميين كان يقول ان
ايدولوجيه القوميه
اليوم هناك تحديات كثيره على اساس حتى
الان هناك توتر بين اليمين واليسار
الحكومه وبين المعارضه على اساس ان هناك
تصفيات جديده لزعماء معارضه وهم يقولون
نحن نتمسك بخط الكفاح ضد حزب الاضاءه
والتنميه يعني كيف يكون هذا الكفاح يعني
لا نعرف ولكن هم يتمسكون بمبداهم انهم
يعارضون او يخالفون الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
وطبعا الصعب صاعين يعني
يتردد ايضا
في الطرف الثاني ايضا في زعماء حزب
الاضاءه والتنميه هم يقولون
هنا في داخل تركيا من يظاهر الدول العربيه
او الغربيين وما الى ذلك اذا سيكون هناك
شد الحبل مجددا او تنازع يعني مستمر
بين اليمين واليسار هناك طبعا تحدي
لاكتساب هذا كبير الى حد السنه القادمه لا
يتوقع احد ان يتحسن
انا اردوغان صيد مصطفى هل تعتقد بان
اردوغان يمتلك ادوات يمتلك اليه فعاله
لمحاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه فما يخص ملف
الاقتصادي
هناك ضعف في السنوات الاخيره على اساس
الاهتمامات على الشخصيات الضعيفه هزيله
النبات وغيرهم يعني الخبراء كلهم لا يرون
انه ناجح في هذا المجال ولذلك يريد لرئيس
الجمهور رجب ان ياتي بمهما يعني هو اكثر
خبره في هذا المجال ولكن هو يعني
يتردد في قبول هذا المنصب مجددا علي بابا
جان وغيره كانوا يعني
هم يديرون اصلا ضفه الاقتصاد ولكن استغنى
عنهم رئيس التركي
ولذلك لديه مخيبه العمل او بروده لتجاه
الحكومه يعني يتعاونون احيانا ولكن لا
يلتصقون به اقصد مهما
يكون بمعنى انه سيستعين ببعض الاسماء ذات
او يقدمون لها اليه حتى يخرج مما يعتبره
الاتراك مازق لاننا نتحدث عن معدل تضخم
نتحدث عن
تراجع في القدره الشرائيه نتحدث كذلك على
العمله التركيه على الليره التركيه التي
انخفضت بالفعل سيد فائق هل تعتقد بان
موضوع الاقتصاد سيكون الاكثر حساسيه
الاكثر صعوبه على اردوغان في داخل التركي
بالتاكيد يعني سوف من الام في السعاده ان
هذه مساله الاقتصاديه سوف تحتل يعني موقع
الصداره في اجنده السيد رجب ولكن انا لا
اعتقد ان في فتره قصيره حتى على مدى
الوسطى يعني يتمكن من يفلح في طبعا معالجه
هذه المساله اقتصاب بل انا اعتقد ايضا اذا
حاله استمر يعني
المساله اذا استمرت بهذه الحاله واعتقد
السابقه السفر
الاقتصاد فهناك شيء اخر انه السيد رجب
تايبر طبعا يعني كتب في يعني ونشرت ايضا
في الصحف السيد جبل اردوغان يريد ان يغير
تقريبا حكومه الاعضاء حكومه اعضاء حكومه
او يجددوا تقريبا 80% يعني بالنسبه
لانها ليست صحيح يعني ما اتحدث عنهم السيد
مصطفى
محمد الشيخ هو ليس يعني مهدي المنتظر ولكن
لابد يعني فن الاقتصاد لا يمكن ان تنقذ
كود كل هذه المسائل بالرجل واحد يعني
يتضرر الامر يتطلب فريق كامل
خبير جدا في هذا الاوضاع طيب على كل سنبقى
في متابعه كل هذه النقاط والاكيد هناك ذلك
تحديات فيما يخص السياسات الخارجيه ربما
نتحدث عنها ولكن في حلقه اخرى
اشكركم الجزيل الشكر على المشاركه معنا من
اسطنبول مصطفى محلله سياسي ومن اسطنبول
كذلك سائق بلوت المحلله السياسي شكرا
لكمما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات